hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game from round six of this
year's sing filled cup it is han smokin
emon vs wesley so and if you are
interested in what's been going on with
uh well with magnus and with him leaving
the tournament there is still no
confirmation from any official source on
what what actually happened so as soon
as there will be i will uh be informing
you guys promptly but now getting back
to the game hans already played against
some very very strong players this
opponent he he defeated aronya he
defeated magnus he uh drew against
talireza but in a really really wild
game and now he faces yet another world
champion as you guys know wesley is the
world official random champion or the
chess 960 champion or the chess 9lx
they're trying to call it that i'm just
not buying it uh so it's either chess
960 official random i'm not going with
the whole uh 9lx thing uh but you know
to each his own
uh so uh you know definitely a very very
difficult opponent so let's see what's
uh what happened in this game hans has
the white pieces and he opens with pawn
to e4 uh wesley replies with e5 we have
knight to f3 and here knight to f6
wesley goes for the better of defense
and hunts um uh well accepts the
challenge head on knight captures on e5
sorry about that uh this is going into
the the classical variation of the
petrov we have d6 and not knight to f3
we have knight captures on e4 and now
pawn to d4 now another possible tricera
will sound like bishop to c3 or knight
to c3 and everything is perfectly fine
for both white and black here at d5 we
have bishop to d3 and now bishop to f5
now adjusted adding another defender to
the knight we have castles and now
bishop to e7 we have rook to e1 and now
wesley castles knight b to d2
now you're attacking the knight on e4
three times so you should do something
about this and you don't want to capture
on d2 as they say usually to take is a
mistake so just go back knight to d6
over a trade of light square bishops but
not knight to f1 han says all right if
you capture i'm gonna develop my queen
and of course wesley wants the same
wesley wants hans to capture so he can
put his knight on the very active f5
square so c6 adding a defender to the d5
pawn and bishop to f4 uh putting
pressure on the knight here and the
knight is defending the bishop on f5 so
uh wesley just eliminates the bishop the
bishop captures and the three queen
captures and now
knight to a6 this is the only move
that's um being played in this position
there is a game between esi penco and to
do that that ended in a draw overnight
the d7 was played but other than that
attempt at a surprise at night the a6 is
the is the move and then you want to
switch it to the c7 to e6 and so on uh
so tonight's the e3 we have knight to c7
and now uh there are a couple of games
that reach this position for example
ananda i had it against the vidit and
anand played rookie to d1 in this
position yoongi had it against baijinshi
he played rook to e2 in this position uh
getting ready to double up quickly on
the e file but hans plays b3 it's a new
move and never been played before so as
of move 14 we have a completely new game
adds support
at the c4 so you know that once this
knight comes to e4 you will of course
try to undermine it with c4
so knight to e6 challenges the bishop
and now bishop to e5 by hans and this is
uh
probably one of the intricacies of the
position that of course both wesley and
hansa imagine all very well uh but as
the engine gives the bishop captures on
d6 as the top move uh there's obviously
a difference between bishop captures and
bishop to e5 uh hans plays bishop to e5
and now he keeps the bishop not the
bishop he keeps the dark square bishop
but he allows this knight to land on e4
and that's why probably uh the the
engine doesn't uh approve this uh
uh says that the knight should be
eliminated so here c4 trying to
undermine the e4 square of course now if
captures then you just blunder the
knight knight back to f6 and rook a to
d1 we have g6 now by wesley and here uh
pawn to g3 now you could also consider
h4 right away at some point you want to
eliminate this knight and push h5 hunts
first goes for g3 we have a6 and now
rook to e2 now with the plan of doubling
up on the e file rook to e8 by wesley
and now h4 getting ready to trade and
push h5 so wesley beats him to it he
plays knight to h5 and now c captures on
d5 we have c captures on d5 and now uh
hans plays knight to g2 starts
remaneuvering the knight he wants to
have more control over the f4 square so
he can push g4 for the moment the g3
pawn is controlling that f4 square and
that's a very important square as both
of the knights can go to f4 so he wants
to gain control of the f4 square and
then push g4 and start an attack against
the black king however i will mention
there is the possibility of playing b4
here and it's quite the move uh of
course the
pawn cannot be captured if you capture
queen b3 you attack the bishop if the
bishop moves this pawn is hanging also
the d5 pawn is hanging which is
obviously much more important so
whatever you play just knight captures
on d5 and then uh
uh of course hans gets a past uh past
d-pawn so b4 here uh is definitely the
way to go and even of course if wesley
doesn't capture which he wouldn't you're
still going to play queen b3 put
pressure on d5 and it's a completely
different game uh but hans played
knights the g2 he's going for the king
side attack and now wesley plays f6 and
this is the only end the direct and only
way of refuting uh hans's idea and if uh
of course if you calculate everything
that comes after f6 then you would
probably decide to play b4 there
uh problem is you don't have a good
square for the bishop you can play
bishop b8 which is what hans did as the
knight on e6 is undefended or you can
play bishop f4 uh but this just allows
that uh capture fest here you open up
the white king you play queen d7 you put
the bishop on d6 and it's gonna be
well unpleasant uh at best so instead
bishop the b8 by hans now hoping to
trade bishop for knight here on e6 but
wesley just plays king f7 and it's uh
it's the uh it's the strongest move in
the position and now hans has to do
something about the bishop here and you
really don't have a square now now you
don't want to go back to f4 if you
wanted you would have played bishop to
f4 on the previous move now even if it
was the strongest move you would not
play it chess players just don't do that
so hans plays g4 uh chases away the
knight we have queen captures uh rook
captures sorry not real captures but
queen captures uh it's important not to
take with the rook but with the queen
because you need to keep control over
the f4 square so g captures on f5 and
not knight f4 attacking the queen and
the knight here and also the rook so uh
the trade must uh happen here you could
also consider h captures on g6 first but
it doesn't really change anything it's
merely a move order so captures captures
captures with check captures and the
rook d e one hunts occupies the e file
and it seems like um it's a it's a
pretty equal position the material is
equal hans has nicely doubled rooks on
the e file but wastely shows that with
bishop to d6 the doubling of the rooks
and the e file is completely irrelevant
because wesley can very easily uh traded
them off and now he has a very firm grip
on the position here if the for example
the knight moves could get very very
dangerous so here hans traits rook
captures rook captures rook captures and
now of course not king captures because
queen captures on g6 first uh wesley
needs to throw in a nice check to defend
the pawn and only then will he recapture
on e8 so came to f1 and now king
captures on e8 and now you have this end
game it's a bishop against tonight of
course queens are still on the board uh
where black will always be a little bit
better as black's king is is much safer
and it's uh it's an open game the place
on both sides of the board so a bishop
will always be a little bit better than
a knight
so here pawn to a4 by hunts grabbing
more space on the queen side also very
important to keep those pawns on light
squares king to f7 we have queen to e3
and now bishop to f4 chasing away the
queen queen back to d3 and now queen h3
check we have king e2 queen to e6 check
and hans goes back king to f1
he would be very very happy with the
draw here and the wesley uh of course uh
not interested in a draw here as here
only black can push for the win plays
queen to e4 uh he wants to trade queens
and of course he would very much like it
if hans just captured so wesley can uh
uh connect his pawns this would give
hans the the past deep on but the
position is already lost because the you
will not be able to keep the pawn yeah
your knight is attacked let's say move
with knight g1 king already goes to e6
and if knight e2 you're just going to
play bishop to d2 and there is no move
basically here for white if the knight
moves or even if it doesn't the king is
coming to d5 it's such an ugly position
to have
so of course he cannot allow this he
plays queen to c3 and now bishop back to
d6 we have king to g2 queen to g for
king f1 and now even king to e7 we have
knight back to g1 by hans and now queen
to f5
queen to e3 with check and again queen
to e4 so uh here you played knight's day
two and the game continues however hans
played king to e2 uh he wanted uh will
improve the position of his king and
increase the activity but now he allows
wesley such a spectacular move that um
well
after wesley plays it of course hans
realized what a great mistake king the
e2 was but i will not of course just
show it to you feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this
incredible move for wesley
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game because that's
the only way you're gonna find this one
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is bishop to h2 that's
the good stuff you attack the knight and
now uh what is there for white to do you
know that once uh white captures the
queen black recaptures connects the
pawns then it's all over the king just
comes to d5 and this end game is lost so
we're not gonna go there so what can uh
hans do here of course he has to do
something about the knight if you move
the knight to h3 then uh king d6 uh of
course just uh uh wesley would uh start
increasing the activity of his king and
now there's really no good way to
get this knight into the game and you're
basically paralyzed there's no good move
for you to make here so hans plays
knight to f3 but this is even worse now
wesley plays bishop to f4 and now hans
has to trade queens there's no other way
to do it you cannot keep the queen here
you're going to lose it and you can't
move it because of the pin so queen
captures with check the captures
attacking the knight and not knight to
e1 but king to e6 and we already
discussed what a terrible position this
would be for hans knight g2 goes after
the bishop just bishop b8 now he's
putting the bishop on a7 goes after the
pawn and that's pretty much it knights
the e3 we have bishop to a7 and now pawn
to d5 with check there's no there's no
possible way for you to to defend this
pawn you could play knight to c2 but
it's such a sad position this knight
will just be stuck here guarding this
pawn so hans instead goes for a pawn to
d5 with check uh but just king to d6 and
now next move wesley can capture the
knight and eliminate the pawn so hans
tries knights the g2 he tries a little
trick of course if wesley captures
knight will eliminate the g6 spawn and
then
give give huns the past h pawn but
wesley doesn't have to react to this he
just plays king to e5 we have d6 now uh
hans has to win some squares df or
square uh for example for his knight so
he he insists on giving up the pawn king
captures now knight f4 attacking the
pawn and g5 is the only winning move but
it's not a difficult one to spot as it's
the only way to not lose a pawn so g5
captures captures and now knight to h3
attacking the pawn g4 now knights to g5
and king to e5 now
uh and uh again a very very very sad
position for hans he plays knight to f7
check just king to f4 and now king to f1
uh how do you how do you win this for
wesley well if you go king of three
obviously hans will just bully you with
the knight so you can't go
that way so here wesley just wastes some
he plays bishop to b6 and now he gives
hans the move saying that whatever you
play okay you can't really push those
pawns you you can play b4 but it's i
mean
at some point you will have to play
something and if you play something like
king e2 then we just play e3 create a
pass pawn and that's it for example
captures uh with check captures and now
uh this pawn
will win the game the bishop will be
nicely covering the queening square so
instead hans played knight to d6 but now
that the knight moved now you go king to
f3 so knights the c4 attacks the bishop
just bishop captures on f2 now wesley's
up two pawns knights the d to check here
king to f4 wesley finishes the game with
a beautiful piece sacrifice but even
though a temporary one it's a very nice
way to end the game so it was in this uh
position on move 59 that han smoke and
even resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so you have
to capture the bishop once you capture
it e3 comes with check and even though
you will win this pawn as well uh of
course this pawn will now queen let's
say king f3 king e1 g3 you can even
allow the white king to blockade the
pawn uh because there's no move white
can make uh whatever you try if you go
here then king f2 and if you push the
pawn uh then of course black will
happily just bring anything into the
game even a rook rook will also do
nicely let's say rugby b1 check king h2
and now rook to h1 will be checkmate uh
so there you have it uh but after king
f4 han saw that there's no point in
continuing he resigned and a brilliant
brilliant victory for the world official
random champion wesley so and again if
you think about it the this game could
have been a completely different game if
instead of knight g2 hunts played b4
here and he realized the plan of going
after the d5 pawn uh but that's just it
even if i i believe even if you just
analyze your own games and you know
you will see that in
most critical positions b4 is always the
answer
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very very nicely done by
wesley just a complete domination out of
the petrov defense uh which you know
just shows absolute class
uh so there's that and also here are the
standings as we haven't checked out the
standings so these are the standings
after round six uh sorry about that let
me just uh enlarge this a little bit
it's from the official uh singfield cup
uh twitter page
uh so wesley so uh leading the
tournament followed by with three points
fabiano alireza and janipomshi with two
and a half points levon arne enhanced
him in linear dominguez uh which to
maksim vashilagrav and shahir mamayarov
again really not having the best
tournament in last place with one and a
half point
uh so yeah there you have it hope you
guys enjoyed it we're gonna cover at
least one more game from round six so
stay tuned for that uh and yeah uh yeah
uh always be mindful of that possibility
of pushing the pawn to b4
uh i would like to thank wood uh paul
certano which is csf5 ravishing reptiles
youtube and another casual coder for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the singfield cup until it
finishes so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day